[Music]
hello there river babes
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and this is
the very last episode of Sweetwater
secrets for Riverdale season 2 now I am
very excited because I'm back in the
dress that started it all that's right
this is from the first episode of
Sweetwater secrets and today's last show
is all about our overall hisses and
kisses of season two and as a a bonus
bit of Awesome the Riverdale stars are
spilling there hisses and kisses too now
this is all very special to me because
when I started the process of creating
the idea for Sweetwater Secrets I knew I
want to come up with a fun segment that
would allow me to critique the show in a
nice way of course that would also get
the fans involved too now each week
I've loved getting to share my hisses
and kisses with you all and then reading
all of yours in the comments has been
absolutely amazing so thank you so much
river babes for sharing your thoughts
with me each week it's been amazing and
while we're on that note let's take a
look at some of your hisses and kisses
for all of season two here we go now
kicking things off Emma McGuire wrote
kisses to Cheryl's development in s2 she
literally went from attempting suicide
to having a supportive girlfriend and a
family that loves her yes she also added
hisses to Hyrum for being annoying all
the time agreed and ammo added kisses to
every couple on the show and kisses to
the amazing storylines hisses for
anything to do with the black hood and
hisses for putting Betty's through so
much the season she also added so
excited for season three me too I'm so
excited
meanwhile and Cauldron posted my biggest
kiss of the season is to Betty my girl
has went through so much and really
deserves more credit preach also Lily's
voice deserves more credit I'm just
saying this is
and Theodora camel also commented hisses
to the whole black hood storyline it
took up so much screen time that could
have been used to explore characters
like Kevin and Josie instead and I don't
think it needed to be dragged out the
whole season especially since the reveal
was so underwhelming I agree the whole
black hood storyline was just acceptable
moving on though
Katie Carlton gave us her take saying
kisses to Shoni
just for existing yeah I need more Shoni
and I saw all of your comments saying
how upset you guys all word that so many
Cheryl and Tony scenes were deleted from
the season and I'm right there with you
so fingers crossed we're getting more in
season three and lastly okay I believe
you added kisses to Cheryl shooting Hal
and hisses to Nick st. Claire's
existence yeah I think we can all agree
on that one Wow as I've said before one
of the coolest parts of creating
Sweetwater secrets has been hearing from
all of you River babes and another
incredible part has been connecting with
the Riverdale cast so often and getting
their takes and teases about the show so
when I caught up with the stars at the
CW upfronts last week I asked the cast
to spill their hisses and kisses of
season two and their answers were pretty
fantastic
take a look hisses and kisses
so kisses are the stuff that I really
like yeah kisses yeses ooh like so
hisses things I didn't like
more Betty and keV as a hiss it's a hiss
and a miss and it makes me real pissed
it's quite a mess it's quite a mess
don't be a man and I just go tests
hisses hisses Jughead getting beat up
and hisses fangs getting shot what do
you think this is hisses for me working
with this guy kisses working with this
guy Casey Cole everybody on set you know
everyone's great hisses I don't know if
there's any hisses maybe I'm not I think
everything on the show maybe a hiss is
when they don't have that Nutella powder
croissant at crafty we have everyone who
loves this one quits on it every time I
don't see it everyone goes for it and it
just gets it gets wiped out within the
first two minutes that's a test I need a
second that's the only hiss I can think
of hisses I think I would have left
Betty and chuckin apart for longer you
just broke all their fans hearts well I
I think narrative Lea its to build the
tension of them being apart and their
inevitable reignite of their
relationship is something that we could
have prolonged a little bit but I really
don't have too many kisses of this
season no I mean I wanted to see more of
the friendships I think this season was
super focused on everyone's families you
know so we didn't get to interact as
much as we would have hoped but I think
season 3 is gonna be a lot more focused
on the friendships I hope and so you
know Betty and Kevin will be able to be
a nice little duo and you'll see more
B&B and maybe Betty and Archie get to
hang out a little bit more even though
he's in do
I hope he gets out let me know what's
happening with that I feel like I have a
lot of kisses I don't know that I have
too many dissing
okay some of the kisses working with
Charles it's been great
been you Reggie that's been it's been
really good to have a have a laugh on
see every now and then and Cole we've
been working together a little bit more
than the last season so we're kind of
stuck with that but we're still waiting
for our characters to actually like each
other for once I think Hyrum is a huge
kiss I thought he really brightened up
that family storyline and I think he's
fantastic yeah I mean I think Hyrum at
the beginning of the season I had no
idea what was really going on with that
and now you see that he's obviously a
villain but I think it like was okay I'm
gonna say what every watching was named
Joe kisses Cheryl becoming a serpent
kisses us being transferred over to
Riverdale south at North I'm I really
loved the scene of Archie and Betty and
the black hood when you were digging the
grave I really loved that scene I
thought that was a kiss the kisses I
really liked jugheads narrative arc like
I had mentioned I think unlike season 1
Jughead this season was a character you
you could hate a little bit more and
dislike and see fault within and I think
for me that's a much more interesting
narrative than a character that's sort
of just this cute working like I got a
hat I love you Betty I mean I love
Buckhead I really do I ship it and I
love watching them act together I think
they have a lot of chemistry and kisses
to buck heads it's a buck heads to
barchi kisses to barchi - I love Archie
I think buck head has just been from the
beginning so I like you know it took
longer for Archie develop and I'm
excited I think part she in season 3 I
mean I have no idea we haven't heard
anything about it but I
feel like there's like room to grow with
our cheese any other kisses Lily okay
it's kind of a kiss I mean yeah yeah I
like the couples on the show and I think
we need to see more of moose and Kevin I
think a lot of people really like that
that was a literal kiss that happened
Wow so you know a lot of like open mouth
kissing people people love Cheryl and
Toni together I think that's a super
cool relationship that hopefully will be
explored in season three as well I think
you know they deserve some some more
screen time with their relationship so I
hope that we see that I just love that
entire cast and I cannot wait to get
back on set so I can bring you all the
inside scoop on season three now before
we go here are just a few more of my
personal hisses and kisses for riverdale
season two let's do this now first up in
hisses you know that one's going to the
fact that Josie and Kevin did not get
the attention or the storylines that
they deserved breaking up the Pussycats
was just extremely disappointing and
Kevin seemed to spend most of this year
as the Riverdale sidekick not about it
hisses - the fact that the character of
Hyrum took too much time away from the
other characters arcs and the entire
black hood storyline was frustratingly
drawn-out and ultimately just
underwhelming which is so sad to say as
for kisses now I already told you guys
all of my kisses from every single
episode but when I think of this season
as a whole my kisses are going to all
the relationship developments I loved
VAR Chi's unwavering commitment to each
other
bug heads passionate yet rocky arc -
finding their way back to each other
and phalluses deeply emotional moments
together
I also especially loved seeing the fact
that Sheryl and Tony's relationship
blossomed into something really special
and I'm glad that they're representing a
positive LGBTQ dynamic on the show so
fingers crossed that they're going to
get more screen time in season 3 and
speaking of season 3 I've got great news
now so many of you guys have been asking
and I can officially tell you that
Sweetwater secrets will be coming back
later this year for Riverdale's third
season now I've had so much fun with all
you River veins this season and I'm so
excited to continue our journey together
but first I want to hear from you
because I need your help
now hit the comments right now or tweet
me with your thoughts about what I
should keep on Sweetwater secrets for
next season
should I keep doing a preview show in an
after show or should I just do one do
you like when I recap the episode with
the blue and gold breakdown
should I keep highlighting the romantic
moments in seven seconds in heaven or
should I just make the whole episode my
hisses and I don't know all I know is
that I'm really looking forward to your
thoughts and what you liked from this
first season of sweet butter secrets so
I can continue making this a great place
for Riverdale fans lastly if there are
any other TV shows that you're super
passionate about do you think we should
do another recap II type of show for
tell me but for now please give this
video a like and feel free to tweet me
all summer long if you're going through
Riverdale withdrawals and in the
meantime keep an eye out for my summer
series ship worthy the only show devoted
to the top couples on TV and the first
episode is live and all about why I love
bug-head
and I love you guys thank you so much
for a great season and I'll see you in
the fall for more Sweetwater secrets
kisses to you river babes
[Music]